i just spent the whole week out in new
york and i was shooting with um
dusty low kane ross swish and ron suno
um
but the the whole brooklyn gang ship is
crazy bro
i mean i'll tell you this when it come
to gangs brooklyn always been crazy
because like when when blood like when
blood popped off in new york
and caribbean popped off to new york
like first of all in new york
but these guys are getting like like if
you listen to these records like between
the
the woos and the what's the truth and
all that i don't know so look
i'm just speaking like from when i was
when i was a teenager bro like
if you was a [ __ ] in new york you was
tough because new york is a blood like
you're not like
yeah yeah i always think of new york
it's like raw i just think of jim jones
like la la is a [ __ ] for sure new york
100 percent but the thing about the [ __ ]
in new york is
in prison bloods run everything ain't
the same with the [ __ ]
so the thing is is like for me on the
outside looking in
i see what i've seen in the 90s now like
in the 90s when gang [ __ ] popped off in
new york because it was coming from out
of jails
bloodshed came from out of jail when it
came to the streets it was bad because
people was adapting a jail mentality
before going to jail
so and and how they acted militant all
that [ __ ]
and then like seeing these kids now i
just be like yo bro
even when i think about these like when
when i be talking to dudes from from la
yeah
and like some of them like they they've
gangsters respect gangsters or right
but like they a lot of them that don't
jack like you know bloods or crips over
there i'd be like yo
that's your fault like that's your kids
bro like that's
that's offspring of you right of course
so it's like seeing this [ __ ] bro
it just a lot of it rubs me the wrong
way in brooklyn you got little kids
getting hit with strays and [ __ ] that
[ __ ] just happened while we were out
there we were just in
in uh where where did it happen at
no no i was in brooklyn there was some
some some kid got hit there was a
shootout and some i think a little girl
got hit in the chest yeah right outside
of a liquor store oh no bro it's that
but that's the thing it's like
i don't know because you know i i don't
i don't sit on like i'm born in 82
my generation be acting like we we sit
on this this pedestal where we had
everything right when we didn't
you know of course we did there was just
not social media kind of it was not
social media but it's like
even the rationalization of like why
things were done it still don't make no
sense but it's like now it's like
it's even i think it's even worse now
because it's like
the name recognition amongst your peers
i got a 14 i got a 19 year old daughter
i got a 14 year old son
so it's like i be telling my son all the
time bro like i got a friend that went
to jail for attempted murder and he just
was telling me like wayne
i belonged to myself for the first time
he just got off the papers and he like
i just i belong to myself for the first
time how crazy is that and i'm telling
my son i'm like yo do you hit it i say
bro
i tell my son like yo he shot somebody
when he was 18. and he just
and he's now finally free of the system
he's 40 bro
i'm like you don't that's not a pat you
used to get because his friends
yo bro my son certain kids that was on
his basketball au team
i didn't see any instagrams they'd be
carrying hammers and [ __ ] i'm like this
is crazy [ __ ]
and i don't even know why but i know
that a lot it plays into the music in
the lifestyle
and it's a lot of misinformation that
spread i mean it's a lot of
misinformation i just be trying to do my
part
because i feel like you change the world
by changing one person's perspective